je m'appelle negro TV je vais
juste nous décrire brièvement votre travail
comment le décririez-vous à quelqu'un
qui ne l'a jamais vu avant de le voir
je ne suis pas doué pour décrire ce que vous
voyez c'est comme si vous aviez besoin d'histoires d'images anciennes
et  parfois la vie d'aujourd'hui ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui à quoi ressemblait notre vie à quoi
elle ressemble en ce
moment  d'
une image que vous avez faite avec un disque des Beatles
et un tourne-disque ou l'image de
Sedna fumant une cigarette pouvez-vous
nous dire pourquoi vous êtes également intéressé à
explorer une sorte de vie moderne à Cape
Dorset Je n'y ai jamais vraiment vécu
un  nouvelle vie une autre époque
où ma mère ma mère est née ils
vivaient dans le camp je vis nous vivons dans
une communauté mais nous sortons toujours sur la
terre c'est là où j'ai grandi la musique
comme les Beatles différentes générations
et certains artistes même jeunes  des artistes comme
vous certains d'entre eux ha  J'ai dit qu'ils avaient en quelque
sorte peur de faire des images plus modernes dans
leur art, ils avaient peur de s'attaquer aux
problèmes sociaux dans votre art, ils craignaient que cela
ne se vende pas, vous semblez ne pas
avoir cette peur pourquoi est-ce que je veux dire
parfois j'ai  un sentiment fort
comme celui que tu évoquais dit fumer sympa
et
bouteilles secrètes autour d'elle la pollution c'est
ce que je vois même si quand on
sort en bateau on voit des ordures flotter
c'est pas très sympa et d'où vient l'
image du coup comme fumer
qu'est-ce que vous essayiez de
transmettre dans cette pièce ou qu'est-ce qui a
inspiré cette pièce ce n'est pas seulement
notre terre qui est polluée c'est notre
société la drogue l'alcool
vous connaissez une petite communauté et pourquoi
pensez-vous que c'est important de le représenter dans
votre art  c'est c'est un problème c'est un
problème qui doit être résolu et
vous savez que vous faites beaucoup d'art où nous
voyons beaucoup moins vous avez mentionné l'
environnement et vos préoccupations concernant l'
environnement et je me demandais  f
vous pourriez parler brièvement du
changement climatique et de la façon dont il affecte le
cap dorset, il a affecté la communauté,
je sais que c'est le cas lorsque deux jeunes hommes ont perdu
la vie parce que là où il y avait
de la glace, ils ont perdu la vie
, c'est donc très clair  chose à
coup sûr c'est déchirant
c'est la fonte précoce des glaces rien ne signifie moins de
temps passé sur la terre ferme tu sais la pêche
c'est ça qui a affecté nos vies c'est juste la
vie de tous les jours non mais c'est comme très
parfois effrayant effrayant comment tu te connais je
m'inquiète de ce que si nous ne  je ne reçois plus beaucoup de
nourriture de la mer ou de la
terre oui maintenant le coût de la vie
y apparaît salut
mais je me demande si c'est intéressant
parce que votre art est si populaire dans le
sud
peut-être que votre art aide les gens à
voir ce qui se passe vraiment  se passe
ici dans le Nord que nous ne voyons pas
parce que peut-être que le Nord ne reçoit pas
autant d'attention qu'il le devrait
bronzer f  loating premier quand j'étais dans le
monde entier avec mon monsieur et je suis je commence coca
coca-cola ours tu sauves longtemps l'
ours polaire en arrière nous voyons des canettes de coca-cola
flotter alors et quel était le nom
de cette image le le  ours polaire
avec le coke et éjectez l'ironie vous
êtes l'un des artistes les plus célèbres et les
plus connus de la collection
quand j'ai moi-même fait la queue à
ces le jour de la
collection d'impression a publié vos images sont
certaines  du premier à être vendu avant même que
nous n'y arrivions pourquoi avez-
vous décidé d'aller au collège de l'Arctique pour
étudier pour devenir enseignant
quelque chose de difficile
peut-être devrions-nous enseigner à nos
enfants vous savez que les
choses changent quand votre ouais  vous savez,
mettez quelque chose en eux pour qu'ils grandissent
et fassent des changements. Je suis curieux de savoir quel conseil
donneriez-vous aux jeunes artistes qui essaient
d'établir leur carrière dans le nord,
peut-être pas seulement à Cape Dorset, mais
dans tout le nord, n'abandonnez pas
n'abandonnez pas il y en a beaucoup  différentes manières pour
chaque personne a un temps différent
bien essayer avec ce que vous êtes bon au
travail dessus et ensuite cuisiner Je sais que vous venez
d'une famille d'artistes célèbres que
pensez-vous que votre père penserait du
succès que vous avez  eu
oh vous serez si fier je suis je suis très
sûr oui bien merci beaucoup ouais
nous allons essayer de vous rendre les gars